une cour d'école déserte pas très
étonnante un mois de juillet ici les
bourses ont fini tu les cartables ou de
livres le contrôle mais la porte est
restée ouverte
ce qui de parfum de vacances des
surveillants pour revenir
d'habitude on vient ici pour travailler
pour étudier pas ça fait bizarre parce
que c'est la première fois que j'aime
parce que j'ai pas trop ce qui viennent
on fait connaître en même temps un
collège cette semaine j'ai fait à telle
époque
la semaine dernière les musiques les
danses les fûts création d'un site
internet visite du musée du loup depuis
trois semaines cinq animateurs sont là
pour donner aux jeunes d'aubervilliers
une autre vision il avait partout
vas-y vas-y ça fait changer toutes les
images en fait mais on a une autre image
des enfants on les connaît un peu mieux
que nous connaissent un peu mieux ce qui
fait qu'après pendant l'année les
rapports sont plus les mêmes exactement
ça s'améliore et effectivement vivre au
collège quand tout est fermé le collège
est en panne ou pendant les vacances
celle de sandy vee ces collèges de fait
en ce temps ses croyances et ses idées
pour les derniers spectacles visites
surprises un tailleur bleu lui le nombre
de caméras sûrement quelqu'un
l'important c'est une visite de l'école
sur leur seule mais pour eux le bilan
est simple
ça m'apporte le bonheur